[Music]
well i think what our new framework
is going to do is it's going to make it
more likely that people
at the margins of society can
participate in our labor market
we're not going to preemptively start
raising interest rates when we see
unemployment getting
extremely low unless we see signs of
inflation
and i think what that will do is mean
that the economy will have
some extended stimulus and that will
allow more people to get jobs
for a much longer period of time
[Music]
by the federal reserve act the federal
reserve has two mandates
one is stable prices to make sure that
the price level does not fluctuate too
wildly
and the other is maximum employment to
try to make sure that the economy is
operating as robustly and as large as
possible
we work to try to manage that through
an interest rate policy as well as other
tools that
we have at our disposal
the phillips curve is a relationship
between employment
and the level of prices so what the
phillips curve says is that
as we get employment and labor markets
that are tighter and tighter
inflation will get more and more intense
and so as you get closer and closer to
our full employment levels you should
see according to the curve
spikes in inflation that could move the
economy into
a much less stable position when it
comes to the price level
so what the philips group tells us about
employment is that as
levels of employment go up as you get to
labor markets that are tighter and
tighter
that's going to put pressure on wages
firms are going to have to compete more
to get workers
and that will translate into higher
prices for final goods
high inflation in the 1970s was really
detrimental to the economy
the tyranny of double-digit inflation is
our common enemy in 1974.
do i feel angry sure the experience in
the 70s
certainly was a a marker and it
allowed the fed to really reflect and
come to a conclusion that they didn't
want to have that ever happen again
and so there is a propensity and has
been a propensity
to proactively prevent inflation from
spiking to very high levels
when people say the phillips curve is
flattened what they mean is that we're
not seeing the same
type of response in the price level to
very high levels of employment that we
used to
so that sensitivity to tight labor
markets
is not triggering inflation in the
marketplace
and to that extent what it means is that
if you drew that curve out
it would show a much flatter
[Music]
relationship
[Music]
what we see in terms of our general
employment levels and this
many of the national statistics are
really averages of a number of different
relationships
and so we actually try to dive more
deeply into that
and and see how different segments of
the economy are performing and
and how workers from different
experiences and backgrounds
are experiencing the economy the data
has been pretty clear on this for quite
some
time that the employment for minorities
has lagged that for the general
population
and if you look at unemployment rates i
think the the the basic rule has been
that
unemployment rates for our
african-americans has been about
twice that for the general population
well the natural rate of unemployment is
basically the level of
employment that you would see if
everyone who wanted a job
could have one and it was not going to
trigger inflation
my estimate of the natural rate of
employment has really changed over my
entire career
when i started in my role here the
estimate was more in the four and a half
percent range
i've really perceived that the natural
rate has fallen even further
somewhere south of four percent maybe in
the 3.7 to 3.8 percent level
and that's really informed how i've
thought about what appropriate policy
should look like
well i think we've learned a lot over
the last seven or eight years since the
the great financial crisis and all of
the signals that we've learned have
suggested that
we can be a bit more patient in
increasing rates in responding
to very tight labor markets so i think
moving forward what we will expect
and what i expect we'll see from the
committee is a willingness to
keep rates lower for longer and really
wait for signs of inflation
before moving to a more proactive policy
approach
the higher inflation is a challenge for
people that have constrained incomes
and constrained wealth and this is one
of the reasons why as we think about
what appropriate policy is we keep those
people in mind and make sure that
we are doing all we can to understand
the challenges that they face
but one thing i would say is that if
we're going to have an economy that
works for all people
monetary policy is just going to be one
tool for that we're going to need
investments on the fiscal side as well
as in state and local
governments to make sure that there's an
infrastructure so that people can get
the skills
that that allow them to have higher
wages so they can manage
and prosper in an economy that's growing
[Music]
robustly
[Music]
you